[Music]
the woman who's accused Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh of sexual
assault is demanding an investigation
before she testifies on Capitol Hill
Christine Blasi Ford says the FBI should
look into her allegation that Cavanaugh
assaulted her more than 35 years ago
before she appears before the Senate
Judiciary Committee her lawyers say in a
letter this a full investigation by law
enforcement officials will ensure that
the crucial facts and witnesses in this
matter are assessed in a non-partisan
manner Nancy Cordes is on Capitol here
where the Judiciary Committee still once
Ford and Kavanagh to testify at a
hearing on Monday Nancy good morning
good morning and Republican leaders push
back immediately on Ford's request for
an FBI investigation they said it won't
change what she plans to say publicly so
she should go ahead and testify on
Monday as they have proposed but her
lawyer in an interview said that this is
too serious to rush through and that her
story deserves to be checked out this is
being rushed through and it's too
important to be rushed through it's not
a game in a scorching letter to
Judiciary Chairman Chuck Grassley the
attorneys for Christine Blasi Ford said
their client had endured death threats
since going public forcing her and her
family to relocate while dr. Ford's life
was being turned upside down her lawyers
wrote you and your staff scheduled a
public hearing for her to testify six
short days from today an FBI
investigation of the incident should be
the first step she will talk with the
committee she's not prepared to talk
with them at a hearing on Monday an FBI
investigation would take weeks time the
GOP is reluctant to burn Republicans
extended a hand in good faith tweeted
tennessee's bob Corker if we don't hear
from both sides on Monday let's vote
chairman Grassley argued nothing the FBI
or any other investigator does would
have any bearing on what dr. Ford tells
the committee so there is no reason for
any further delay Ford a psychologist
and professor says the Supreme Court
nominee pinned her to a bed put his hand
over her mouth and groped her at a high
school party Brett
Cavanaugh says that's completely false
we should not be rushing to judgment
with a sham hearing on Monday that is
designed solely to create a he-said
he-said he-said atmosphere republicans
say the democrats should have shared the
allegations earlier they had weeks to
bring this up and we're not going to
reward their conduct many senators have
already taken sides what if anything
could Judge Cavanaugh say in this
hearing that would convince you that he
didn't do what he's accused of he is
saying that he didn't do it what else
can he say so I set that aside and I
look at what dr. Ford is saying left
unsaid here is the political reality
that there is a midterm election coming
up in just a month and a half that could
change the balance of power in the
Senate so Republicans have every
incentive to push this through as
quickly as possible and Democrats have
every incentive to stall Norah that's
right as it looked like Democrats could
even retake that the Senate Nancy thank
you